the moment has come
this show is so beautiful
I called the sea family and over the
last three and a half years we've become
so close
we thought that we had accomplished
something really big and exciting
together this is the last time I'm doing
a roll like this I'm gonna give it
everything I got
uh
something's different
they have the ability to see
now it will come for us
I like to have fun and this show is
unbelievable
I love being a father and I love
fighting for my family and I love Baba
and sacrificing himself so that they can
win
it's been a long time brother
what made this show special is the show
about family it's a show about a father
a mother and two children trying to
figure out their lives in a very
complicated world
the level of imagination is just out of
this world everyone that's been on this
show from props sets costumes just cares
about it and loves it we work so hard to
make it special and there's just nothing
like it
what I love about this show that's about
people that don't have sight is they are
heroes and bad guys and they have
emotions and they're looked at in a way
that people with outside have never been
looked at
our goal was to make it the most
respectful show making sure that we
change the world of entertainment for
people who are blind or low vision
Joe stretches absolutely invaluable
there wouldn't be a show without him
he's a producer he's blind and he's
there to further the development of the
characters in the best way possible
we're going to use our ears to listen
right we're not looking at him speak
we're listening to him speak right
there's just so much thought that goes
into how we build things because we want
to be inclusive and because we want it
to make sense in the world
one of my favorite things about sea that
no one knows
but anyone who's ever worked with me
knows
if I'm a natural born Thief
look at that and that's going to look
great in my trailer
it was definitely the most challenging
production there was a really great
sense of camaraderie on set and I think
everyone was just really excited to see
this through to its completion
one of the best things about playing a
character on a long-form series like
this is you get to grow with the
character it's truly been incredible
it's been a very exciting Journey going
through this life three years that is
really a beautiful thing about acting
you know you create a person and you
kind of step into their body for a while
and then you sort of let them go
you might hate me but I know you still
love me
from day one we just all kind of melted
together in a way that felt really nice
and natural and I'm gonna miss that most
I think
I remember the first time I met Jason
Momoa he came in with such a presence
and energy his creativity just blew my
mind
it's basically me being a six-year-old
boy dream come true this kind of role is
someone who I was in a past life living
out every childhood fantasy I've ever
had look at that there's like I want
swords in this and this kind of knuckle
knives I love my job
during season two I tore my bicep and I
had a laser surgery just to kind of keep
my arm on so when I'm fighting Batista
in the whole time it's taped on look at
that my shoulders Hang On by the thread
Jason really dedicated everything his
body his emotions and made that
character the ultimate hero the ultimate
father The Ultimate Warrior
foreign
[Music]
people
[Music]
and we created something really special
here
just so I feel me it was the best that
I've ever known
we're really good friends and we look
after each other the book of Baba
wow
[Music]
I just
we grew together and we've been forged
together in a way that I never
experienced with a film team before
as a token of my appreciation oh this is
your dream Guitar Buddy look at that
look at that I hope he's a little
sunshine rays of light like you buddy
thank you very much thank you so much
we've gone through journey within the
show and also a journey within the world
you know with everything that's been
going on the last three years and we
shared it all together like I tried and
so I'll miss that I will die if it's not
allow anything happened to you
Bible verse he's awesome it's a
character that honestly say is my
favorite character I've ever played and
I know I gave everything to it and I
would enjoy watching it for years to
come
I stand with both of us
thank you very much
that's all I got in me I gave it to this
so
I'm beat
[Applause]